[Music]
a race to bring nearly a hundred
wildfires under control in Northern
Algeria
within ours the flame spread through the
forests and agricultural areas in 16
provinces destroying everything in their
Park
people watch helplessly as their
belongings turn to Ash
it started to burn around 2PM just
around the military school I called the
fire brigade and I told them that the
fire had started nearby they got there
half an hour later but in the meantime
the fire had spread
the fire started at gruma on the tablet
side spread through benimala and ended
at burbash some people lost everything
thousands of firefighters have worked
through the night the blazes are being
fueled by strong winds and high
temperatures the defense Ministry says
soldiers are among the dead they're part
of emergency crews responding to fires
in a resort area east of the capital
Algiers
I would like to thank all the volunteers
also a number of provinces contributed
help Manpower and Equipment we're
grateful for that until this moment
we're trying to control the spread of
the fire in the best way the strong
winds made it hard for us to use the
Shoppers in putting up these fires
the winds have pushed East towards
Tunisia reigniting flames in a pond
Forest along the border both Algiers and
Tunis have registered record high
temperatures this week
while wildfires are common in North
Africa during the summer months this
year they are aggravated by blistering
heat wave
um Sharif Al Jazeera